hier au procès villemin à dijon le juge
lambert s'était dit convaincu de
l'innocence de la roche aujourd'hui le
commandant de gendarmerie cesma
expriment un avis contraire
on comprend pourquoi l'assassinât du
petit grégory reste un mystère dominique
verdeilhan eric de lannion l'honneur
d'un capitaine le 16 octobre 84
il fut l'un des premiers sur les bords
de la vologne aujourd'hui
c'était éprouvant je suis derrière
sous la jambe ça faisait huit ans que
j'attendais ce moment soulagement
soulagement de dire que pour lui il
fallait pour suivre la piste la roche
soulagement aussi de dire ce qu'il pense
du juge lambert de son manque de sérieux
je ne veux pas en rajouter par rapport à
ce qui a été dit hier mais avec lui on
n'a pas pu aller jusqu'au bout alors les
médias ont occupé le vide après le juge
jean michel lambert et lui maurice simon
il a reculé son départ en retraite pour
tenter d'élucider la faire jusqu'à y
laisser sa santé
c'est maître jacques les hôtes et qui
fut un moment avocats dans le dossier
grégory qui lui rend un hommage appuyé
et cornemps au passage le juge jean
michel lambert
je ne comprends pas comment avec cette
évidence des chronomètres et du temps
nécessaire pour mettre un enfant à l'eau
qui a été estimé compte tenu des
rapports des médecins légistes à 4 à 5
minutes vois pas comment on peut le dire
que
on croit à la culpabilité d'une personne
comme christine villemin troisième juge
dans le dossier deuxième juge à la barre
jean paul martin il a refermé le dossier
grégory par un non-lieu pour christine
villemin
devant la cour d'assises il fait état
d'éléments qui l'ont poussé à croire que
bernard laroche a enlevé grégory et l'on
relèvera aujourd'hui le sentiment d'un
magistrat exprimés à la barre devant la
cour d'assises
dans un dossier de procédure il y as ni
pleurs ni sueur c'est quelque chose
d'assez petit zay et qui peut être un
danger
mince consolation une cour d'assises
offre aujourd'hui à la justice
l'occasion de donner à ce dossier
une vraie dimension